denis de montpon éditorialiste politique
bonsoir mon chiot merci d'être avec nous
cette affaire décidément créé des remous
fait des vagues
est-ce que christophe castaner selon
vous même s'il a exprimé des regrets
entre-temps a dépassé la ligne rouge et
emmanuel macron droite intervenir et en
tirer les conséquences comme le souhaite
olivier faure enfin je pense que
emmanuel macron seraient bien inspirés
de passes paix de cette affaire mais il
est clair que depuis le début de ce
qu'on a appelé la sphère griveaux le
ministre de l'intérieur outre passe ses
pouvoirs et sa fonction pourquoi parce
que s'y est d'ailleurs le déroulement
des faits l'ont montré c'est une affaire
qui est devenue judiciaire
il est ministre de l'intérieur on ne
sache pas que le ministre de l'intérieur
est addict et ou au parquet au ministère
de la justice qu'il a à faire et dans ce
dossier il a dès le début dès que
monsieur griveaux benjamin griveaux a
démissionné enfin a renoncé à être
candidat à la mairie de paris
il avait dit le ministre intérieur il
faut que la justice soit saisie que les
coupables soient sanctionnés
on ne voit pas à quel titre où il fait
de la basse politique ce qui semble être
le cas quand on observe maintenant les
espèces des changes de cour de
récréation avec olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
alors ça aussi c'est vrai que ça un peu
agité les médias aujourd'hui
mais il faut ramener ça à sa juste
proportion c'est quoi au fond c'est une
sorte de règlement de compte entre deux
socialistes puisque monsieur castaner
était comme vous le savez membre du
parti socialiste
jusqu'à ce qu'ils fassent défection pour
rejoindre emmanuel macron à l'époque
olivier de fort l'avait critiqué pour ça
pour avoir finalement fui le
l'embarcation alors qu'elle était en
train de couler et je pense que c'était
une manière assez peu élégante du
ministre de l'intérieur de l'ue est
renvoyé la monnaie de sa pièce
vous parlez de règlements de comptes on
en a aussi beaucoup parlé dans cette
affaire chacun sur les plateaux de télé
sont allés voilà de leur avis sur les
règlements de comptes peut-être voilà
aider pas aidé quelle est votre vision
vous d'été au réalisme politique sur ce
traitement médiatique de cette affaire
vous avez été étonné à écouter il ya eu
un emballement absolument spectaculaire
pourquoi parce que bon il ya eu cette
vidéo qui a été même pas j'allais dire
et stork et benjamin griveaux puisque
c'est lui qui l'envoie d'abord c'est lui
qui l'a réalisé qu'ils envoient propre à
lui de vouloir s'exhiber comme il l'a
fait ensuite que ça a été diffusée sur
les réseaux sociaux il pouvait s'y
attendre
n'est ce pas et ce qui est contraire à
la loire évidemment de sueur et si ça
doit être fait que sanctionner saleuses
ça le sera mais dans des proportions
assez quand même minime nombreux ce qui
est quand même assez surprenant c'est
qu'il ait démissionné aussi rapidement
parce que vous savez bien que le
libertinage
en tout cas en france c'est aussi vieux
que la politique
d'ailleurs tous les chefs d'état
ministres etc
quand on pense à jacques chirac à
françois mitterrand qui avait des
doubles et des triples vie etc
c'était salué comme quelque chose de
très mal de très viril
voilà et je parle pas de nicolas sarkozy
et de françois hollande aussi donc on
vous allez vous attirer des ennuis sont
encore là nommé se situe ça ce sont des
flèches totalement établie et que l'état
ait connu de ce qui est surprenant dans
le cas de benjamin griveaux c'est que
tout d'un coup pour une vidéo comme ça
qui circulent il passe pour la victime
et toute la classe politique
ce jeu fait cancer en réalité et je
tiens seuls 2
d'un responsable de la république en
marche que s'est il passé
c'est que il avait réalisé un sondage
quelques jours plus tôt et benjamin
griveaux était en train de dévisser dans
les sondages il était même tombé à 13 %
le vert david belliard était passé
devant lui et la république en marche
craignez que il ne passe sous la barre
des 10%
pourquoi parce que ça aurait été pour
lui et pour tout la macro ni un désastre
politique de voir que le parti au
pouvoir n'arrivent pas à s'implanter
dans une ville comme paris
puisqu'on souvient que en 2018 avant la
crise des gilet jaune
emmanuel macron c'était à l'époque
engagé et avait dit qu'il s'engagerait
dans la campagne des municipales et le
stanislas guérini quel responsable du
parti avaient même tablé sûr 10 me
d'élus donc en gros vous êtes en train
de vous dire que cette affaire
le fait de piotr pawlowski et non ses
complices on ans à venir encore
puisqu'une enquête est en cours a
finalement d'une certaine façon rendu
service à la macro ni bon on peut le
lire comme ça en tout cas bien entendu
car au fond comment savent-ils griveaux
rang prétexte de de ce scandale alors
bon la méthode est répréhensible et tout
ça bien sûr mes rivaux prend prétexte
de la mise sur la place publique de
cette vidéo sexuelle de ce sextape comme
on dit maintenant pour pour jeter
l'épongé
mais concrètement et juridiquement rien
ne l'empêchait de poursuivre la bagarre
au contraire il n'aurait peut-être même
plus s'attirer des sympathies dans le
public
alors c'est quand même assez paradoxal
de parler de la politique du libertinage
qui est vieux comme la politique sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il ya peut être un fait
nouveau dans cette affaire c'est que
c'est le citoyen qui d'une certaine
manière à une pouvoir de décider du sort
d'un politique
on savait très bien que dans les
rédactions il y avait des photos sur
mitterrand qui n'ont jamais été
dévoilées on connaît les conséquences
que ça use
quand paris match a révélé effectivement
des photos sur la vie privée de nicolas
sarkozy aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas
ça la grande nouveauté est ce qui peut
choquer finalement tous ces politiques
le monde médiatico-politique que le
citoyen alors on juge nous parle donc
c'est pas légal mais en tout cas j'ai vu
ce pouvoir et sur le destin d'un pôle
innovant mais bien sûr il ya un
phénomène nouveau ses réseaux sociaux et
la déflagration que ça provoque encore
que cette vidéo a été assez peu vu
puisqu'elle a été très vite retiré ce
kia elle a été twitté par quelques
personnalités et c'est ça qui a provoqué
les dégâts
mais c'est vrai que vous avez raison de
rappeler c'est que françois mitterrand a
une double vie bien avant d'entrer à
l'elysée
et ce n'est que quand il l'a décidé que
on a eu connaissance de cette double vie
de l'existence de sa fille cachée
mazarine etc etc
et c'est peut-être ça la différence
aujourd'hui bien sûr gérer beaucoup bien
sûr ce qu'avant on avait affaire à l'est
pas par ati on l'a vu avec françois
hollande quand il s'est fait pincer rue
du cirque où il allait retrouver julie
gayet alors même que le que là la
première dame
était valérie trierweiler que
effectivement ça mais ça a amusé la
galerie plus qu'autre chose voiliers et
c'est vrai que benjamin griveaux a été
comme un dieu comment dirais-je surpris
de la la déflagration parce que c'est
les réseaux sociaux c'est par définition
instantané ça peut être très très vu ça
ben ça passe circuler autant que serait
circuler si la vidéo était restée en
ligne
mais quand même il ya les journalistes
qui l'ont vu et vous savez dans le cas
de françois mitterrand
les journalistes accrédités et qui était
mitterrandolâtre il était au courant de
l'existence de mazarine mais simplement
il y avait une espèce de d'omerta de loi
du silence alors même qu'aujourd'hui on
nous dit attention vie privée vie
publique
il faut faire en question en avant et un
après
l affaire griveaux selon beaucoup
tantale penser en réalité benjamin
griveaux n'a pas jusqu'à plus ample
informé
bon il y là il a comme comme on dit fait
une connerie en se présentant dans cette
vidéo tel qu'il se présentait mais il
n'a pas fait de faute politique de ceux
de ce point de vue là il n'a pas on peut
pas comparer à un françois mitterrand
qui avait une fille cachée et pour
comment dirais-je élevé cette fille
cachée et et çà et là mère de sept
enfants utiliser les fonds de la
république mais c'était un autre cas de
figure donc griveaux su finalement une
goutte d'eau dans dans un océan quoi et
je ne pense pas je ne pense pas que ça
comment dirais-je change le
fonctionnement de la vie politique
il est certain que d'autres gens seront
à l'affût pour piéger les politiques
mais c'est aux politiques de faire
attention
merci en tout cas denis demonpion
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
français